Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wo sind wir? Was tun wir?
Wir sind vor dem Salon und wollen noch ein paar Dinge besprechen,
bevor wir dann in den Salon treten.
Und zwar hörte ich gestern Radio und zwar meinen Heimatsender SWR4 und dort
gab es einen Gerätesender.
Oder wird da Musik gespielt?
Da wird Musik gespielt, ja. Schlager.
Die alten Sachen, aber auch, muss ich gestehen, zu viel Neues.
Ich will ja die alten Schlager hören. Aber darum soll es jetzt nicht gehen,
sondern es gab dort einen ganz kurzen Bericht über, naja, ich kündige es mal
gar nicht an, sondern sage, wir haben ja gerade diese großen Debatten.
Junge Leute sollen sich mehr engagieren, so eine Dienstpflicht täte ihnen gut,
Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht, man muss auch mal hinaus ins Leben gehen,
auch gerade muss man die Arbeitswelt kennenlernen.
Bist du nicht eifersstandener?
Es kann auch Lust machen auf dann einen Beruf, an den man vorher nicht gedacht
hat und das ist ja etwas, was jetzt in der Debatte so da ist und dann denkt
man sich, ah ja, das ist interessant,
aber es gibt ja auch schon so etwas ähnliches, was nur freiwillig ist,
nämlich das freiwillige soziale Ja.
Genau, das wurde ja nie abgeschafft, auch als die Wehrpflicht ausgesetzt wurde.
Ganz richtig, aber dann hört man folgendes.
Es sind bekanntlich die kleinen Dinge, die das Leben ausmachen.
In diesem Fall ein wenig Nähe, Zuhören oder ein vorsichtiges Streicheln.
Leanne Manuel ist FSJlerin in einer Seniorenresidenz in Ingelheim.
Die 17-Jährige macht das, für was im stressigen Pflegealltag oft zu wenig Zeit
bleibt, nämlich voll und ganz da sein, ohne enges Zeitkorsett.
Wenn ich fertig mit der Pflege bin, setze ich mich zu den Leuten,
die hier noch im Speisestall sitzen, unterhalte mich mit ihnen,
Gebe ihnen Essen, falls sie noch nicht gefrühstückt hatten.
Gebe ihnen Trinken zwischendurch, damit sie halt auch mehr trinken. Und ja ...
Also ich unterhalte mich viel mit den Leuten. Für die Seniorenresidenz sind
FSJler wie Leanne schon längst unverzichtbar.
Finanzielle Kürzungen würden das Haus in Ingelheim daher hart treffen,
befürchtet die Leitung der Einrichtung.
Denn darum geht es. Jetzt soll tatsächlich dieses Programm,
das ja diesem Ideal von Menschen, junge Menschen engagieren sich,
gehen auch dorthin, wo sie sonst nicht so häufig sind, zum Beispiel in ein Seniorenheim,
erleben dort die Gesellschaft einmal anders.
Jetzt soll dieses Programm gekürzt werden.
Man muss sagen, es sind derzeit mit dem Bundesfreiwilligendienst zusammen 100.000
junge Menschen pro Jahr machen eine FSJ.
Das sind also schon ziemlich viele. Die bekommen wenig Geld.
Da wird auch nur von einem Taschengeld gesprochen, nämlich 450 Euro im Monat.
Also wir haben 700.000 pro Jahrgang. 100.000 sind sehr viel.
Ja, das ist sehr viel. Und jetzt, wenn wir mal weiter, also da habe ich gedacht,
das kann doch gar nicht sein,
dass wir zum einen darüber diskutieren, wie kriegt man alle zu einer Dienstpflicht
bewegt und hier hat man schon etwas Freiwilliges und will aber jetzt hier sparen,
damit dieser Dienst nicht mehr so weiter gemacht werden kann.
Wir profitieren von den FSJ-Lern dahingehend, dass sie die Möglichkeit haben,
weil sie nicht so aktiv in dem Pflegealltag mit drin sind, dass sie sich Zeit
nehmen können für unsere Bewohner, Dass sie sich dazusetzen können,
dass sie einfach das auffangen können, was die Pflege aufgrund des Zeitmangels,
den sie hat, einfach nicht leisten kann.
Und wenn das wegfällt, dann ist einfach die Lebensqualität unserer Bewohner
nicht mehr die und nicht mehr so, wie wir sie gerne haben möchten.
Um gegen die geplanten Kürzungen vorzugehen, protestieren sie heute.
Unterstützt von der Politik machen sich in der Mainzer Innenstadt ganz unterschiedliche
Wohlfahrtsverbände Luft.
Denn Gelder für freiwilligen Dienste zu streichen, wäre auch perspektivisch ein Desaster.
Was man ja nicht sieht, nur wir
beide sehen es. Deswegen muss ich die Entrüstung kurz für das Publikum.
Dort demonstrieren nicht etwa die Omas dafür, mehr Zeit mit diesen Leuten zu
verbringen. Auch nicht die Angehörigen dieser Omas.
Sondern es sind die Jugendlichen selbst.
Und die Verbände Johanniter etc. Rotes Kreuz.
Unglaublich.
Das ist der reine Wahnsinn und das ist auch eine winzige Demonstration,
die da vor dem Staatstheater in Mainz stattfindet.
Es gab aber, muss man sagen, schon vor einem Jahr diese Kürzungswünsche.
Da gab es Demonstrationen, die haben offenbar geholfen, denn das Kürzungsprogramm
wurde dann nochmal verschoben. Oben jetzt aber sollen Kürzungen stattfinden.
Es ist auch noch unklar, wie viel.
7,5 Prozent oder gar 20 Prozent soll gekürzt werden. Und da fällt dann sehr viel weg.
Es passiert, dass wir viele Freiwillige haben, die den Dienst erstmal machen,
um das Fachabi zu bekommen oder einfach ein Jahr zu überbrücken und die dann
einen Beruf kennenlernen,
der ihnen unglaublich Spaß macht, der ihnen unglaublich viel bietet,
wo sie einfach neue Einblicke bekommen und durch diese Einblicke dann wirklich
den Weg in den Beruf finden.
Sei das die Pflege zum einen, wo wir es ganz stark sehen. Es ist aber auch zum
Teil der Rettungsdienst und es ist aber auch in der Kita ganz stark.
Mit dem Protest heute ist die Hoffnung verbunden, dass die Bundesregierung ihre
geplanten Kürzungen noch einmal überdenkt.
Ansonsten werden viele soziale Einrichtungen, die personell ohnehin oft genug
am Limit sind, weitere schmerzhafte Einschnitte spüren.
Mir braucht also niemand mehr von der Bundesregierung irgendwas erzählen von,
ja wir müssen mal die jungen Leute für irgendwas motivieren.
Die werden hier gerade so aggressiv demotiviert, dass man nicht mehr mit Dienstpflicht
oder irgendetwas ankommen muss.
Dieses Gefüge ist so schräg. Wir sehen hier Menschen, alte Menschen in Pflegeheimen.
Das betrifft ja nur 20 Prozent der zu Pflegenden in Deutschland.
80 Prozent der Pflege findet ja privat statt.
Was bedeutet, da ist es so ein 1 zu 1 Betreuungsverhältnis von jemandem, der da...
Sag ich jetzt mal grob, klingt immer ein bisschen provokativ,
wenn ich das auf einer Bühne mache, kommen dann immer gleich Vorwürfe,
die das nicht gerne machen.
Die Schwiegertochter pflegt ihren Schwiegervater, den sie vor zehn Jahren erst
kennengelernt hat und von dem sie nichts weiß und der jetzt dement ist und ihr
Gegenüber vielleicht auch gewalttätig oder so, dem pflegt die nicht gerne.
Also ich würde sagen, diese Leute sind ja eigentlich gut aufgehoben.
Ich hätte einen anderen Vorschlag für die Bundesregierung.
Statt zu kürzen, das Ding einfach erweitern, sodass man so eine ambulante Tagespflege
aufmacht, dort, wo eh schon diese jungen Leute sind und sich engagieren.
Also dieser Essensaal in einem Pflegeheim für 80 ältere Leute einfach so dimensionieren,
dass da auch 300 reinpassen, sodass die nächstgelegte Nachbarschaft da auch
noch hingehen kann, obwohl die da gar kein Bett haben.
Ja. Und da dann in so ein, wir spielen, wir singen, wir bewegen uns ein bisschen,
in Zusammenhang zu kommen.
Weißt du, wo sowas ein bisschen stattfindet bei solchen Premium-Senioren-Residenzen?
Die haben ja ein großes Kulturprogramm und das ist immer geöffnet für alle.
Die haben auch ein Restaurant, in das man gehen kann, wenn man von extern ist.
Das heißt, da sieht man die Durchmischung, aber das ist dann nur auf dem Premium-Level.
Das müsste man aber eigentlich überall haben, dass man eine wirkliche Durchmischung der Gesellschaft hat.
Und es würde aber auch bedeuten, dass man darüber nachdenken,
wie weit man FSJ erweitern kann, dass also zum Beispiel die Angehörigen,
die pflegen, mehr entlastet werden durch FSJler.
Das würde alles aber auch bedeuten, dass die in meinen Augen sehr viel mehr Geld brauchen.
Also 450 Euro im Monat ist auch zu wenig.
Ja, wenn du jetzt sagst, Premiumhäuser machen sowas, also 80% dieser Pflege,
die zu Hause stattfindet, also da finden gar keine Geldströme statt,
außer man holt sich nochmal für den Sommer Unterstützung von dieser polnischen
Oma, die sich dann an Urlaub finanziert, die kostet 1000 Euro im Monat,
obwohl das Arbeitsgericht da schon gesagt hat, da ist auch Mindestlohn,
da ging ja eine große Entrüstungswelle durch Deutschland.
Deutschland, Pflegeheimen, 2.000, 3.000 Euro im Monat.
Wenn du jetzt von Premium sprichst, dann sind das die typischen 5.000.
6.000, 7.000.
8.000 Euro im Monat Häuser. Also da ist man dann im Top 2% der Boomer oder deren
Eltern, die jetzt gepflegt werden. was eben bedeutet, dass da dann auch Erbe aufgezehrt wird.
Das ist ja eine der großen Schicksalsfragen jetzt, man kann sie hier nochmal nennen.
Möchte man, dass seine Oma von einer 450 Euro Pflegekraft und so weiter,
bedeutet das, man selber muss dann einen Pflegeplatz organisieren,
der so viel Geld kostet, wenn die Oma da zehn Jahre lebt, sind das 300.000 Euro.
Das Haus, das man eigentlich erben wollte, ist dann weg, ist dann verpflegt.
Dafür hatte man aber zehn Jahre lang die Oma in den Händen oder die Mutter.
Also das sind diese kleinen Abwägungen, die nirgendwo besprochen werden,
aber die Millionen Menschen jetzt,
mit ihren Geschwistern klären müssen, wie sie es organisieren.
Naja, es gibt ja die Möglichkeiten der vorzeitigen Schenkung.
Das nehmen dann manche Leute wahr.
Das heißt, die überschreiben das Haus.
Ja, und dann geht das ja über Pflegestufen. Das heißt, wenn das Haus erst mal
überschrieben ist, werden ja Kinder nicht gleich mit eingebunden.
Das ist ja ein Kampf, den die SPD erfolgreich geführt hat.
Wir haben, glaube ich, schon einmal darüber gesprochen, dass man mit einem Einkommen
von unter 100.000 Euro im Jahr,
also das ist ja schon beachtlich, dass man dann nicht eingebunden wird in diese
Art, dass es so sehr stark an das eigene Vermögen geht.
Aber wir haben keine Pflegevollversicherung. Also die Oma,
die sich die Pflege aus der Pflegeversicherung in-house leisten kann und nicht
auf ihr nur 95.000 verdienenden Sohn zurück.
Da sind wir hier so selten wie mit Rentenanspruch über 3000 Euro.
Das sind dann 40 Leute in Deutschland.
Bei 18 Millionen Rentnern. Das ist alles dramatisch. Nicht gut.
Und was hast du für uns dabei? Du hast E-Mails gelegt.
Ja, wir lesen, ich versuche es jetzt zu institutionalisieren.
Was eine Institution ist, lernen
wir ja gleich bei Precht, eine Derivation und so weiter und so fort.
Aber vielleicht können wir euch, weil wir kriegen sehr viele Kommentare, aber immer überall.
Und vorhin kam auch wieder die Frage in der Instagram-Direktmessage,
wo soll ich denn jetzt kommentieren? Also neue20er.de,
Jeder Salon, jeder normale Podcast hat dann einfach einen Post und dann stehen
da ganz normale Blogger-Kommentare drunter. Kann man einfach hinschreiben,
weil dann könnten es auch alle sehen.
Ich lese also jetzt E-Mails, die nur wir so bekommen haben, mit kurzen Hinweisen.
Zum einen Tim zum Vapen. Das ist ein Themenvorschlag für uns.
Er ist tätig an einer Schule in einer deutschen Großstadt und sagt,
der Konsum von Vapes, Also diese Zigaretten, die eine Batterielaufzeit haben,
die also nicht einfach nach drei Minuten fertig sind, scheint ein echtes Problem zu sein.
Also zehnte Klassen, die komplett süchtig sind.
Und dadurch, dass sie es auch in der Schule, weil es ja kein Feuer und so,
alle Toiletten, aber es stinkt ja nicht mehr, es riecht ja als nach Himbeere
und so, aber hier scheint es große Abhängigkeiten zu geben.
Ich will dazu auch nochmal anmerken, weil wir das letzte Mal über die Ottfried-Preußler-Schule
gesprochen haben und ich da da sagte, kein 17-Jähriger schafft es heute mehr,
einen zusammenhängenden Text zu schreiben.
Stimmt natürlich nicht. Ich habe zum Beispiel, wenn auch leider nur bei YouTube,
eine Diskussion verfolgt zwischen Michel Friedmann und Veit Selk,
der das Demokratiedämmerungsbuch geschrieben hat.
Da haben nach so ungefähr einer halben Stunde auch zwei Schülerinnen und Schüler
Platz genommen, um Fragen zu stellen.
Und das waren die besten Beiträge.
Also es war wirklich eine Sensation, denen dazuzuhören. Nicht nur inhaltlich,
sondern auch in so einer, man kennt das ja, Friedmann ist da,
der wird so ein bisschen aufgehitzt, aber jeder möchte noch den Ton wahren.
Also es fällt dann so alles auseinander und die beiden haben das wirklich sehr gut gemacht.
In der Hinsicht möchte ich das ein bisschen korrigieren. Es gibt ungefähr ein paar...
An einer Hand absehbaren Prozentbereichen, die doch noch in der Lage sind,
ordentlich mitzudenken und das dann da auch tun, was ich sehr gut finde.
Außerdem dürften jetzt alle wählen mit 16. Das ist natürlich auch ein erstrebenswerter
Zustand, wenn man so hört, wie zum Beispiel im Deutschlandfunk,
wenn immer Schüler anrufen und so weiter, wie das dann klingt.
Da wird ein bisschen vernünftiger diskutiert.
Außerdem wurden wir darauf hingewiesen, dass diese Debatte um die Ottfried-Preuster-
Schule viel größer sei als der Beitrag, den wir gespielt haben,
das dargestellt hat und das ist es tatsächlich eine fundiertere Auseinandersetzung
gab und dass auch tatsächlich die Lehrer sich nicht hinter den Schülern versteckt haben,
in dem Beitrag aber schon, den wir gesehen haben und sich aber publizistisch
in der Süddeutschen lang und breit geäußert haben.
Das nehmen wir zur Kenntnis.
Klüger wird die Debatte deswegen nicht.
Ich glaube, generell würde ich auch schon mal gerne gerichtlich darüber verfügen,
dass niemals irgendetwas nach mir benannt wird, Um nicht später solche Debatten zu haben.
Das ist wie Schwarzenegger mit dem Schwarzenegger-Stadion da in Graz oder so,
wo er dann auch aus Amerika zurief, nehmt dem Stadion einfach den Namen.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf die Diskussion, ob ich hier jemand begnadigen soll
als Gouverneur oder nicht und ihr kommt da von der anderen Seite der Welt.
Gut, Arthur schickt uns einen Hinweis auf die Conny-App.
Du hattest ja angeregt, eine Blitzerwarnung mit Mietpreise. Ja. Es ist die Conny-App.
Ah.
Die Conny-App, also C-O-N-N-Y, da kann man seine Erfahrung mit dem Vermieter
einfach reinschreiben und ich habe es mir nicht genau angeschaut,
aber da werden die Einhaltungen der Mietpreisbremsen überprüft,
überprüfbarer gemacht.
Ja.
Also für alle da Betroffenen. M.F.
Fremd hat zu Beisenherz kurz kommentiert, dass ihn das sehr an die Familiensituation erinnert.
Ich betone das ja im Fernsehpodcast auch immer wieder, dass die Journalisten
auf die Ampel gucken, als sei das so eine Familie und wenn die sich nicht verstehen,
dann ist alles schlecht.
Hauptsache sie verstehen sich. Ob danach was geregelt wird, ist ja egal.
Hauptsache man versteht sich.
Finde ich sehr gut. Max weist auf die bessere Kriminalstatistik hin.
Für alle, die sich da interessieren, kriminologie.de.
Da findet man eine Studie, in der Soziologen und Kriminologen auf das Polizeiwissen
zugreifen und schon der erste Satz im Abstract lautet,
im Jahr 2022 kam es in Deutschland zu einem postpandemischen Anstieg der polizeilich
registrierten Kinder- und Jugendlichen-Kriminalität.
Also für alle, die ansonsten das auch sehr genau nehmen mit dem Angriffskrieg
Putins im Namen Russlands gegen die Ukraine.
Die werden hier aufgefangen. Das ist sehr gut. Ben hat Höcke und Vogt kommentiert
und zwar mit dem Spruch, den auch Friedmann Veit Selk gegenüber machte.
Ich habe das gestern als 90 Sekunden lange Frage, die Friedmann in den Raum
stellte, mal getwittert, nämlich, ja Herr Selk, ja Herr Poss,
also der Hamburger CDU-Mann.
Jetzt sagen Sie mir doch mal, was ist
jetzt der Unterschied zwischen den demokratischen Parteien und der AfD?
Ja, und Veit Selck lacht nur kurz und POS will so reinspringen,
aber Friedmarie Brems die noch kurz und sagt,
nee, erstmal lassen wir den Povi hier ein bisschen nachdenken und danach Ende
dieser Clip, den ich gemacht habe, weil dann kam auch nichts mehr und ich möchte
anregen, wenn es keine Unterschiede gibt, nicht irgendwelche herbeireden.
Wenn man ein Buch über die Dämmerung der Demokratie und der Demokratietheorie
schreibt, also ein Abgesang des Geredes über die Realitäten.
Und dann kriegt man die Frage, ja, aber in der Realität, was unterscheidet jetzt CDU und SPD von AfD?
Und man hat eine CDU, in die irgendwie, ja wir können auch den Ausländern,
ach nee, es sind ja Deutsche, aber diesen Zweitpass, den Deutschen mal nehmen,
weil es sind ja keine Biodeutschen, ist ja nicht so schlimm, wir denen das nehmen.
Oder Olaf Scholz sich eben zitieren lässt mit, wir sollten jetzt mal im großen
Stile, und der Spiegel publiziert es auf Englisch, mit Deportation,
dann gibt es da keinen Unterschied zur AfD.
Dann sind sie an diesem Punkt nicht unterscheidbar und dann kann man nur von
außen stehend beobachten, dass man offensichtlich mit rechtsradikaler Politik,
rechtsradikaler Parteien nicht verhindert.
Punkt. So. Und so schreibt auch Ben. Aktuell ist der Konsens bezüglich der Flüchtlingspolitik
durch die Reihen von CDU, SPD, selbst den Grünen und ebenfalls eben auch der
AfD, dass Flüchtlinge, die nach Deutschland kommen, eigentlich schlecht sind.
Das ist aber ein Land, in dem Menschenrechte schon wichtig sind.
Deshalb muss man irgendwie den Spagat schaffen. Genau so ist es.
Wir könnten doch diese ganze Debatte jetzt über das, was Biden mit den Flüchtlingen
an der Grenze zu den südamerikanischen Ländern macht,
genauso nochmal rezipieren wie damals das, was Trump gemacht hat.
Und dann Dann würde man sagen, wie unmenschlich, was macht der denn da?
Wir können das genauso machen wie bei Trump, machen das aber nicht so.
Sondern das wird jetzt als ja, natürlich nicht einfach und auch schwierige Entscheidung.
Nur de facto ist es dasselbe. Es gibt keinen Unterschied.
Biden macht menschenfeindliche Politik dort, Trump hat sie gemacht.
Trump hat das mit einer anderen Rhetorik versehen. Aber im Resultat gibt es da keinen Unterschied.
Und das glaube ich ist, wenn ich einen Unterschied herausarbeiten sollte,
das, was man jetzt sehr gut sehen kann, auch auf diesen Wahlplakaten,
wenn die FDP da schreibt,
wir kümmern uns um Migrationssteuern, bevor die anderen es tun.
Das ist natürlich feiner ausgedrückt, wie eine Beatrice von Storch das sagen würde.
Absolut.
Ja, nur wenn wir jetzt dann nur noch auf die Etikette gehen,
dann kann man dann sagen, ja, also man kann sich also unterscheiden,
entscheiden, will man eine rechte Position mit Holzpfeilerhemd und kurzer Hose
oder möchte man gerne eine rechte Position im Nadelschreifenanzug.
Nur der Unterschied im Resultat ist dann nicht auszumachen.
Und ich möchte darauf hinweisen, heute im Salon lese ich das Buch von Gilda Sahebi,
das nicht nur eine sehr gute und sehr dringende, sondern wahrlich spektakuläre
Antwort auf dieses Gefüge, Ja, wie machen wir das denn jetzt mit der AfD und
überhaupt und den Wählern der AfD und so und so, ja?
Also mir ist es dann auch wie Schuppen von den Augen gefallen, wie man es machen muss.
Ich kann sagen, ganz anders, aber wir werden das dann im Wortlaut lesen,
weil es ist wirklich, also ich verspreche heute zwei Gänsehaut-Momente im Salon.
Der zweite, also ich saß gestern mit Humann im Büro, ich will es anteasern ohne
Innerliches, wir haben beide Gänsehaut gehabt.
Okay, ich verspreche auch zwei Gänsehaut-Momente, aber vielleicht eher so Schock-Gänsehaut.
Nee, bei mir beide positiv.
Nein, bei mir ist wirklich so, dass wir sehr erschrocken sein werden.
Ich bekam eine Rückmeldung via Instagram zu meinem Take zur Schuldenbremse,
dass ich jetzt doch für die Beibehaltung der Schuldenbremse bin und dieser Herr schrieb,
ja offenbar haben sie Angst vor der Demokratie und das war genau der richtige
Kommentar, wie ich heute zeigen werde.
Und ich werde mal sagen, ja, aber ihr habt alle unglaubliche Angst vor der Demokratie.
Ich werde ja das Buch von Philipp Mano heute besprechen und der wird uns auch
mal ein bisschen die Leviten lesen und ich will nicht sagen,
er verteidigt die bösen Buben, aber wir werden heute ein bisschen einüben,
Erdogan, Orban verstehen lernen.
Ah ja, okay, gut, wir sind gespannt. Christian schreibt uns,
weil wir ja darauf hinwiesen, dass ich New York Times Texte mit DeepL übersetzt
habe und dann die Überschrift wortwörtlich übersetzt wurde,
obwohl ja die New York Times sehr verspielte Überschriften macht und da so Idiome
vorkommen, die man eigentlich im Kontext übersetzen müsste.
Und das Interessante ist, dass Christian selber bei DeepL arbeitet,
also uns hier wirklich erklären kann, was die Sache ist.
Und ja, wie schon vermutet, ist das begrenzte Kontextfenster.
Denn die Überschrift, wenn man eine Webseite übersetzen lässt,
ist durch, wie nennt er das, harte Linebreaks vom Text getrennt.
Und da ja da spezifische...
Sachen, Techniken, das Übersetzen und nicht jetzt wie Claude oder GPT einfach
so ein Gesamtkontext, Text einfach erstmal sehen, lesen, verstehen und dann
sagen, okay, dann übersetze ich die Überschrift jetzt so.
Klappt das hier wahrscheinlich noch nicht so. Es ist ein dummes Implementierungsdetail,
wie er schreibt, aber man arbeitet daran. Ich denke, es ist irgendwie nicht
allzu kompliziert heute.
Also wir werden nachher die Berlin Summit Declaration lesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon gehört hast.
Aber die großen Ökonomen, vor allem deine Lieblingsökonomen und meine auch,
also von meiner Seite so Südekum und so, aber dann auch der Blanco.
Blanco, Milano wird schon, Adam Tooze und Isabella Weber.
Und wer noch? Die Mazzucato oder wie sie heißt?
Ja, Mariana Mazzucato. Alle haben unterzeichnet.
Deine Gegend hat das geschrieben. Wir lesen es. Ich finde es nicht gut.
Und dann fragen wir mal Claude.
Ich finde es auch nicht gut, interessanterweise.
Und dann fragen wir mal Claude, ob man das besser machen kann.
Ich verspreche, das ist der Gänsehaut-Moment von gestern aus dem Büro.
So, da wird also mehr als nur übersetzt, da wird richtig geackert von der Maschine.
Bernhard weist darauf hin, dass BMW derzeit eine Batteriefabrik baut in Bayern,
die auch mit 100 Hektar recht groß ist.
Wenn man dann diesen Text anklickt, und zwar auf der BMW-Group-Werke.com-Seite selbst,
hat man so ein bisschen die Ahnung davon, dass da nicht einfach die große Einladung
ausgesprochen wurde, sondern sie wollen jetzt hier irgendwas ruhen und überhaupt und so, nee,
wollen wir nicht doch noch ein bisschen Benziner, also dieser Konflikt zwischen
der bayerischen Staatsregierung und der eigenen Industrie scheint wirklich…,
überbordend zu sein, weil Söder einfach nee, Oma Erna hat gesagt,
sie möchte das ja nicht, also ist das nicht. Ja. So ein bisschen wie mit diesen Flutsachen jetzt.
Äh, nö, wir hatten uns doch dagegen entschieden, diese hässlichen Dinge aufzustellen
und jetzt ist alles überflutet, also jetzt ist alles kaputt,
was man in der Sichtachse nicht stören wollte. Also es ist wirklich nicht gut.
Jetzt diese große Frage, ich will es nochmal sagen, also Colin hat so Regression
und Devolution gefragt. Ja. Was ist der Unterschied.
Warum findet ihr die Negation eines biologischen Begriffs so treffend für ein
soziales oder zivilisatorisches Phänomen?
Darf ich erst was dazu sagen? Und zwar geht es ja nicht darum,
wenn man diesen Begriff der Devolution verwendet, wie Veit Selck es tut,
zu sagen, wir naturalisieren historisches oder soziales.
Es ist nur eine Metapher, die gewählt wird, die in meinen Augen sehr viel treffender
ist als das Wort Regression.
Regression meint tatsächlich in der Tradition der Frankfurter Schule,
dass eine Gesellschaft sich nicht einfach zurückentwickelt, sondern es gibt schon eine Aggression,
die dazu führt, wer wütend ist und eine Aggression.
Adorno sagt, wer wütend ist, denkt nicht, ja, und der rekrediert dann.
Und diese Rekression ist dann zum Beispiel eine in den Faschismus.
Hier aber ist dieses Aktive, das Intendierte rausgenommen bei dem Begriff Devolution
und deswegen ist der sehr viel besser,
weil Veit Selk ja auch nicht ein Buch geschrieben hat, das sagt,
und diese sieben Populisten haben leider unsere Demokratien zerstört,
sondern er sagt, Ja, komisch, woher kommen die eigentlich und was bedeuten die und wo führt uns das hin?
Und dann wird es richtig kompliziert.
Ja, also es gibt ein Buch von Christian Stöcker über die Männer,
die die Welt verbrennen.
Das ist in diesem Sinne, da kann man Leute benennen, die vor 30,
40 Jahren genau wussten, was sie anrichten, also die Chefs der Ölfirmen,
die die eigene Forschung dazu gemacht haben und wenn dann Elke Heitenreich heute
in so einer Diskussionsrunde sitzt und da einfach sagt,
naja, die Jungen regen sich immer über unsere Generation auf,
dabei sind wir doch die, die Greenpeace gegründet haben und Attack,
muss man sagen, nee, ihr seid auch die Generation, die in den 70ern und 80ern
die Forschung gemacht hat,
die vorausberechnen ließ, wie der Klimawandel sich gestaltet,
für die wir heute Nobelpreise vergeben, und zwar mehrere.
Und wenn sie dann sagt, ja, was konnte ja keiner wissen, dass der Flug zur Oper
nach Palermo was mit Klimawandel zu tun hat, dann sagen wir,
doch, das wusste man damals.
Und in diesem sozialen Phänomen, dass man es wusste, einiges wussten die Männer,
die die Welt verbrennen, und es anderen nicht sagten und sogar dann gegen deren
Klimaschutzinteresse, was man ja mal unterstellt, handelten.
Da steckt dieses aggressive Moment drin.
In der Devolution nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen, wir lesen nachher also Texte, die uns Claude geschrieben hat.
Und dann sitzt der Claude-Chef, nicht der Chef, sondern so ein Techniker von
Claude, sitzt im Hardfork-Podcast bei Kevin Newton und Casey Newton Ja.
Okay, wie ist Spacey denn?
Und berichtet dort, was sie selber wissen und verstehen über ihre Technik.
Und ich fasse das jetzt mal wie folgt zusammen.
Und zwar inhaltlich richtig, nur verkürzt.
Die wissen, sie haben ein LLM trainiert und sie haben, wie wir auch als Kunden,
eine Zeile, in der sie Text reinschreiben können.
Da wir Menschen mit Buchstaben kommunizieren, schreiben sie da Worte rein,
Buchstaben. Dann sehen sie noch, wie die Maschine diese Buchstaben in Zahlen umwandelt.
Ab dann haben sie kein Wissen mehr darüber, was da passiert.
Und mit kein Wissen meine ich kein Wissen. Die brauchten eine Forensik,
die mussten das ganze LLM einmal mappen, um dann an einem Beispiel mal wirklich
nachzuvollziehen, was da passiert.
Und sie haben jetzt die Vermutung, dass die Modelle selbst nicht einfach nur
token in der Wahrscheinlichkeit aneinanderreihen, sondern dass sie nochmal so
einen kleinen Umweg gehen und Feature,
also Ideen der Welt repräsentieren, die sie in unserer Kultur in Sprache transkribiert
gefunden haben. Das ist aber nur eine Theorie.
Das Einzige, was sie dann sehen, ist, da gehen irgendwie so Zahlen rein,
am Ende kommen Zahlen raus, die werden wieder umgewandelt in Buchstaben und
die sehen wir dann. So, man weiß also nichts darüber.
Und so wie man nichts darüber weiß und eine retrospektive Forensik macht,
so ist das auch bei der Devolution.
Der Falk Selk sitzt da und sieht, dass die Demokratie sich irgendwie zurückentwickelt
und es hat auch irgendwie mit dem Gerede über die Demokratie zu tun,
also dieser Demokratietheorie.
Aber wir können jetzt nicht irgendwem unterstellen, da mit Absicht und so weiter,
sondern wir müssen jetzt wirklich eine latente Sinnstruktur,
eine verborgene Ideologie einfach finden.
Die hat niemand da so reingesteckt und verheimlicht uns das und dann müssen
wir den einfach fragen und sagen, hier sag uns doch mal, was sind die da versteckt,
wir finden die gar nicht.
Also das ist kein Escape Room oder so, den jemand für uns gestaltet hat,
sondern die Realität ist einfach eine verborgene und so ist das in der Natur auch.
Nur glaube ich, müssen wir bei dieser Nähe zur Natur immer auch den Unterschied
deutlich machen, denn die Demokratien in den verschiedenen Ländern sind historisch
gewachsen, sie sind sozial bedingt, sie werden von Menschen gemacht,
während die Natur die Natur ist.
Und deswegen ist es eigentlich richtig, wenn der Hörer da hellhörig wird,
denn man könnte damit auch leicht eine,
konservative, reaktionäre Geschichtsphilosophie betreiben, à la Oswald Spengler,
der davon ausgeht, dass alles in einer ewigen ein Wiederkehr ist und dass es
wie in der Natur Blüten gibt und dann wieder den Winter,
der eintritt und so können dann Reiche aufsteigen und verfallen und das ist
natürlich ein reaktionäres Denken, wo das Historische und Soziale einfach weggeschoben
wird und man es naturalisiert.
Das ist hier bei Veit Selk oder wenn wir diesen Begriff Devolution verwenden,
selbstredend nicht gemeint.
Also unsere Neugier findet nur im Seminar Platz, nicht im Stammtisch.
Also wenn es darüber schwappt, wird es gefährlich.
Keine falsche Verkürzung. David empfiehlt uns sehr interessant,
ich habe es noch nicht angeklickt, habe es aber auf der Liste.
Künstliche Intelligenzkurse der Uni Nottingham.
Wäre jetzt auch erstmal nicht, wieso Uni Nottingham? Das ist eine englische Uni.
Aber die haben wohl relativ viele Vorlesungen und so weiter,
die man jetzt da verfolgen kann.
Scheint mir interessant zu sein.
Was haben wir hier noch? Ja, diesen Preußler Schulfall, also eine sehr lange Mail,
wir haben alles dazu gesagt und Oliver zum Abschluss empfiehlt uns nochmal einen
Hinweis auf KI als Waffe, wo ja genau sowas passiert,
also dass man jetzt eine Technik, die man selber nicht versteht,
die aber wie Harari jetzt immer wieder in jedem Interview darauf hinweist,
selber Entscheidungen trifft.
Die wird jetzt im Krieg angewendet warum? Naja, weil es relativ sinnvoll ist, da diese kleinen,
Zeitvorsprünge und so weiter zu nutzen und er empfiehlt uns eine Doku von Fox
also V-O-X, dieses amerikanische Fox, nicht das deutsche,
wo nochmal erklärt wird, wie Israel jetzt KI benutzt, um,
ich frage mich so ein bisschen, Ziele zu identifizieren, also die haben 80%
der Gebäude zerstört, ob da vorher noch eine Zielerkennung stattfand,
ist so eine Sonderfrage Aber wie da jetzt diese ganze KI-Wende auch in den Krieg
Einzug erhält, kann man wohl, ich würde sagen, auch im Ukraine-Krieg sehen.
Wolfgang Michael hatte gestern einen Freitag-Text empfohlen,
der, wenn man ihn so liest...
Das auch schon mal so als Hinschwenk jetzt zu Precht.
Precht sagt uns, irgendwas stimmt mit unserem Wertesystem nicht.
Wir haben da relativ viel rein investiert und der Outcome ist nicht besonders groß.
Die Diplomatie, die darauf fußt, funktioniert irgendwie nicht so, wie wir es machen.
Und gestern dieser Text von Michael, den er da empfahl, der verleitete zu so
einem Tweet, der ungefähr so klang, ich dachte, es ist nur das Wertesystem kaputt,
aber es ist auch das Wehrsystem.
Also da werden alle von Amerika an die Ukraine gelieferten Wehrsysteme mal so
aufgezählt und was sie kosten und dann wird bei jedem kurz erklärt,
warum die Ukrainer das einfach aussortieren, gar nicht benutzen.
60.000 Euro teure Drohnen, die keinen Sinn haben, weil sie nicht funktionieren
und die Ukrainer planen dann dieselben Einsätze und nehmen aber so 700 Euro
Drohnen, die sie einfach in China bestellen.
Also es scheint hier an allen Ecken zu bröckeln, diese ganzen Ideen,
die immer aufgedröselt werden und die dann so münden in so nachrichtlichen Aspekten
wie, puh, der amerikanische Kongress hat sich doch noch durchgerungen,
die Ukraine zu unterstützen.
Da muss man fragen, ja, was bedeutet das jetzt?
Wann kommt da irgendwas an? Und zweitens, was kommt da an?
Und drittens, macht es einen Unterschied? Und alle drei Fragen scheinen ganz
andere Antworten in der Realität zu geben, als uns einfach nur als Vermutung
noch mitgegeben wird in solchen Berichterstattungen.
Ich will noch einen Hinweis machen zu KI in Bezug auf Gewerkschaften,
weil mir aufgefallen ist,
dass es jetzt ganz viele Panels bei Gewerkschaften gibt über KI und dann ist
immer diese Frage da, bedeutet das das Ende der Arbeit oder ermöglicht uns das
die Arbeitszeitverkürzung, was auch immer.
Ich würde von diesen Themen ein bisschen mal absehen und mal durchführen,
Die Linie so ziehen, dass ich sage, was kommt eigentlich mit der KI,
wenn also so ein Assistenzsystem auf dem Computer installiert ist,
das mit den Angestellten zusammenarbeiten soll.
Es ist nämlich eine permanente Überwachung von Arbeit, wie produktiv ist da
eigentlich jemand und das ist eine Art der Überwachung, die so weitreichend
gehen kann, dass wir uns das noch gar nicht so vorstellen.
Also wir haben ja jetzt auch gewisse Räume, die nicht überwacht werden dürfen auf der Arbeit.
Wir haben also durchaus auch auf der Arbeit einen Schutz, so sind also die Angestellten
nicht gänzlich dem Blick des Chefs ausgeliefert.
Das droht aber jetzt eigentlich durch die KI und zwar so vollumfänglich,
dass man sich fragen muss, wie will man das eigentlich arbeitsrechtlich einhegen,
wo sind da die Grenzen gemacht.
Kann man das gar nicht, muss man einfach fatalistisch davorstehen.
Ich würde sehr dafür plädieren, wenn man sich gewerkschaftlich damit auseinandersetzen
will, genau darauf den Fokus zu legen, denn diese Assistenzsysteme werden jetzt gerade installiert.
Diese Assistenzsysteme sind leicht dann für die Personalabteilung auszuwerten,
wer hat wie viele E-Mails beantwortet oder war doch mal kurz bei YouTube und hat ein Video geguckt.
Also soll man das alles überwachen?
Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Also wir müssen nicht die ganze Zeit darüber reden,
ist das das Ende der Arbeit?
Nein, es ist nicht das Ende der Arbeit. Ist damit Effizienzgewinn möglich?
Ja, das kann man so beantworten, aber zugleich ist das ein Überwachungsregime,
eine Transparenzgesellschaft, die da entsteht, die sehr, sehr gefährlich sein
kann, gerade im arbeitsrechtlichen Bereich und da würde ich mir doch eher Diskussionen zu wünschen.
Ja, die Frage ist dann aber jetzt auch immer...
Angenommen, man wird Vollzeit überwacht. Welche Schlüsse zieht denn dann wer daraus?
Weil, wenn wir das einfach so sagen, ist ja die Bedrohungslage,
du wirst gekündigt, weil irgendwelche
Pausengestaltungen, wie wir es bei Amazon oder so gehört haben.
Nur der demografische Druck sagt ja, die größten Marketingbudgets gehen jetzt
in Richtung Recruiting, dass es den Leuten gut geht am Arbeitsplatz und so weiter.
Es ist gar nicht mehr die Kundenfindung, sondern die Mitarbeiterfindung.
Und in dieser ganzen Diskussion jetzt gerade gibt es in Amerika auch so einen
Strang, der einfach diskutiert, was bedeutet das eigentlich für die Rolle des
CEOs, dass wir die ganze Zeit so einen Schlaumeier da haben,
der es eigentlich besser weiß. ist.
Und der, diese ganzen, in Vorstandsetagen kommt es vor allem drauf an,
dass man da eine gute Show macht und so weiter.
Also dieser ganze softige Teil, dass man irgendwie so Relations untereinander.
Kundenbeziehungen, man bringt so sein Adressbuch mit, das ist der eigentliche
Wert für das Unternehmen und gar nicht so sehr, dass man da eine super Entscheidung trifft.
Und wenn den Unternehmen wirklich so sehr daran gelegen ist,
jetzt kleinste Effizienzgewinne noch daraus zu holen, dass man die Mitarbeiter
so überwacht, insbesondere was die Muster deren Arbeit mal analysiert und so
weiter, dann wird es auch sehr bedrohlich für diese Bullshit-Job-Manager-Riege.
Weil man kommt nicht von der Rolle weg, dass man so ein Repräsentant,
eine Adresse für auch Politik oder so, also Unternehmen ab 1000 Mitarbeiter
haben typischerweise Beziehungen zu anderen Unternehmen, Politikern und so weiter.
Die muss man natürlich, die braucht man, die kriegt man auch nicht wegautomatisiert.
Aber ab der zweiten Ebene, wo es also darum geht, das Haus zu organisieren,
Budgetentscheidungen zu treffen,
da kommt der Mensch wirklich ins Hintertreffen. Bei solchen Sachen.
Nicht so sehr jetzt bei diesem Alltag am Band, ob man da nochmal eine kleine
Pause oder so. Ja, also diesen Euro kann man nochmal rausholen.
Aber bei diesen großen Fragen, da wird es wirklich bedrohlich.
Also wir lesen heute Claude-Texte, die wirklich beeindruckend sind.
Okay, du bist schon wieder gehypt.
Ja, aber ich rede heute nicht über Claude, sondern wir reden mit Claude.
Prima.
Wir vollziehen heute nach, was ich gestern zwischen 15.10 Uhr und 15.17 Uhr
ungefähr gemacht habe. Also in relativ kurzer Zeit.
Und wir kontrastieren das mal
mit einem Tweet unserer Bauministerin zu unserem wichtigen Thema Bauen.
Wo man sich denkt ja, das kommt jetzt im Juni 2024 ganz schöne,
zehn Jahre zu spät und wir kontrastieren mal diese zehn Jahre mit meinen sieben
Minuten und fragen uns mal wo ist der Qualitätsunterschied also es wird ja, it's crazy.
Next Level, wir sind gespannt. Wir sprechen aber zuerst sehr ausführlich über
das neue Buch von Richard David Precht, das Jahrhundert der Toleranz,
Plädoyer für eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik.
Es soll also darum gehen, dass man Außenpolitik betreibt, die nicht nur Interesse
geleitet ist. Das heißt, wir haben in der regulären Folge sehr ausführlich über
den strukturellen Realismus gesprochen.
Das sind Leute, die sagen, Interessen sind das Einzige, was zählt.
Das ist nun einmal so, da können wir gegen diese fatale Logik nichts tun.
Richard David Precht sagt, naja, von Interessen reden alle, die jetzt nicht
auf diesem feministischen Außenpolitikskurs sind.
Herr Friedmünkler, genauso wie Gregor Gysi und wie andere und man denkt,
ja, aber meinen die alle dasselbe oder was ist dann eigentlich damit gemeint?
Und er sagt, nein, es braucht schon eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik.
Wir werden sehen, wie diese aussehen könnte und ob diese realisierbar ist.
Darüber diskutieren wir.
Oder ob er sich nicht mit dem Untertitel, also ob der einfach gar nicht so viel mit dem Buch zu tun hat.
Das ist auch immer so eine Frage, ob das vielleicht so eine Verlagszeile ist,
die man da noch so hinschreibt, die im Text.
Nun, er hat ja, also es ist zumindest normativ. Also er will ein Jahrhundert
der Toleranz und es ist ein Buch, das schon sagt, es gibt Werte und er bezieht
sich ja immer wieder auf den Universalismus.
Wir werden sicherlich da in die Debatte gehen.
Genau, ich will es nur anteasern, weil du jetzt sozusagen den Fokus auf diesen
Untertiteln, die Werte geleitete Außenpolitik und so.
Und wir haben ja auch diese Frage in den Raum gestellt, brauchten wir das nicht eigentlich?
Und gerade weil wir den Realismus da behandelt haben, nur nach Lesen des Buches
würde ich sagen, das Problem, das Precht beschreibt, finde ich, ist zehnmal größer.
Als er das, und ich will nicht sagen übersieht oder nicht wahrnimmt,
sondern als er selbst im Ton es aufgreift.
Was ich interessant finde, weil Precht eigentlich das Gegenteil immer unterstellt wird.
Er hypt die KI zu sehr, er macht zu viel, irgendwelche Anmerkungen und so,
eigentlich ist das doch alles und wir sehen ja auch so richtig anders ist die Welt noch nicht.
Diesmal denke ich, ist er im Ton drunter geblieben, schon allein,
weil er dieses Buch, das ja nun nicht unbedingt wahnsinnig kurz ist,
aber die ganze Zeit nur als Essay beschreibt.
So als hätte er das mal so eben, als würde er so einen Punkt machen,
den man auch im Podcast hätte machen können, aber er würde noch Oma Erna erreichen oder so.
Also ich glaube, dieses Thema wird uns über das Buch hinaus noch beschäftigen,
weil es aus der Realität einen Druck gibt, den man auffangen muss.
Die großen Enttäuschungswellen, die dann Veit Selk mit seiner geruhsamen,
aber deutlichen Art zum Beispiel auffängt, finde ich, habe ich auch schon gesagt,
nee, da müsste man eigentlich mal viel strenger mit umgehen mit diesem Problem.
Also die Demokratietheorie funktioniert nicht heute einfach nicht Mädchen hat
aber mal funktioniert, sondern die war schon immer nicht passend.
Nur damals hat sie halt verherrlicht, was ich als Deko gut, ja,
ziemte, aber es war immer ein schräges Verhältnis und diesmal hier glaube ich auch, diese.
Geopolitischen Fragen sind eigentlich ein bisschen größer, als Precht sie so,
beschreibt und ist, dieser ganze Problemfokus ist für mich jetzt auch so ein
bisschen weggerückt von dieser wertegeleiteten Außenpolitik,
weil da macht er eigentlich kurz einen Prozess mit solchen Sachen.
Beziehungsweise kann man ja sagen, dass man äh,
über die Geopolitik vielleicht nicht so sprechen kann, dass,
nein, ich will es anders formulieren.
Vielleicht ist die Geopolitik etwas, wo man sehr schnell in einen Fatalismus
hineingerät, der einfach die Sache mit sich bringt und das führt dazu,
dass man entweder kleine Schritte geht oder ein übergroßes utopisches Konzept
entwirft, aber alles was dazwischen ist, ist sehr sehr schwierig und ist vielleicht
aber auch nicht besonders intelligent.
Also das heißt, wer sich mit etwas Geistreichem auseinandersetzen will,
ist vielleicht in der Geopolitik gar nicht am richtigen Ort.
Also das müssen wir nachher alles mal besprechen, ist auf jeden Fall ein wirklich
interessantes Buch und ebenso interessant ist das Buch von Philipp Mano,
Unterbeobachtung, die Bestimmung der liberalen Demokratie.
Ich habe schon angekündigt, wir müssen da uns mal mit den bösen Buben auseinandersetzen.
Wie ist das denn eigentlich mit den Verfassungsgerichten? Was ist,
wenn die Populisten kommen und die Gerichte einschränken wollen und in die Verfassung eingreifen,
dann bauen die offenbar die Demokratie ab?
Oder, sagt Philipp Mano, vielleicht doch nicht.
Das ist also ein Buch, das mich sehr aufgerüttelt hat.
Ein zweites Buch, das mich in anderer Weise aufgerüttelt hat,
ist der Roman Trophäe von Gerd Schöters.
Es ist ein Buch über einen Trophäenjäger, ein Mann, der Börsianer ist,
der sehr, sehr viel Geld verdient hat, der aber hin und wieder nach Afrika reist,
um dort Trophäen zu erlegen.
Also Tiere.
Tiere.
Ja, das ist schon die Frage, die sich da zum Beispiel stellt.
Es ist ein sehr finsteres, sehr gutes Buch.
Außerdem ein Artikel, wozu dient eigentlich jetzt diese ganze Aufrüstung?
Wer könnte davon wirtschaftlich profitieren?
Und schon mal Spoiler, es ist jetzt nicht ein Text, der uns sagt,
die Rüstungskonzerne sind so reich geworden.
Ja, klar, aber das ist eigentlich nicht das, was so relevant ist.
Außerdem wollte ich mal wissen, was denkt man denn eigentlich im Umfeld von
Maximilian Krah über die Zukunft der AfD und was da so auf europäischer Ebene passiert.
Deswegen lesen wir mal einen Text aus Schnellroda, um das nachzuvollziehen.
Und wir gucken noch auf Südafrika, dort wurde gewählt und die jungen Menschen
dort sind gar nicht so demokratiebegeistert.
Ja. Sehr gut. Ich bleibe auch unserem heutigen zentralen Thema etwas treu.
Also wie über Sachen reden, die in der Realität nicht einfach so und so.
Also, Gilda Sahebi hat also ein Buch darüber geschrieben, wie wir uns Rassismus
beibringen und unter all den Büchern, die uns vom Rassismus als Opfer nicht
allzu sehr Betroffenen immer nahe legen möchte, hier informiere ich nochmal,
würde ich sagen, ich schaue ja schon gar nicht mehr rein in diese Bücher,
aber hier würde ich sagen, zwingend, insbesondere wegen dieser.
Also du bist begeistert.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein sehr gutes Buch. Da wird chronologisch,
ist einfach eine sehr gute Heuristik.
Also sie wird so ein, sie macht sie die ganze Zeit so einen historischen Aufarbeitungs.
Wir haben zum einen das Gerede und die Gewalt beim Rassismus und das Bedingungsverhältnis
und dann aber auch Geschichte und Gegenwart.
Und in diesem Vier-Felder-Ding operiert sie, ohne das zu akademisch zu machen,
wirklich sehr gut, inklusive Gewaltglosar am Schluss.
Dann lesen wir, Simon Sahner und Daniel Sterr haben ein Buch über die Sprache
des Kapitalismus geschrieben,
das ganz wild aktivistisch uns nochmal sagt, was wir alle schon wissen und die
großen Probleme und Fragen aber einfach umschwimmt.
Also ich greife es auf, weil ich denke, hier kann man auch Verbesserungstipps
geben, plus für den einen oder anderen ist es trotzdem möglich,
das als Geschenk zu verwerten. Also es ist so.
Dann diese Berlin Summit Declaration irgendwas, also namhafte Leute wollen die
Welt verbessern und danach lassen wir die Welt verbessern mit Claude.
Und die Sächsische hat auf die 100-Tage-Bilanz des neuen Pirna-Oberbürgermeisters geschaut.
Der kommt nicht direkt von der AfD, ist aber über die AfD-Liste da eingezogen.
Und sie ziehen einfach mal Bilanz.
Nachdem er ja groß tönte, nach 100 Tagen bin ich bereit, mich beobachten zu
lassen, wird dann mal Bilanz gezogen, was sein Tätigkeitsfeld jetzt umriss.
Das hat mir ein Hörer gestern geschickt und ich habe das so gelesen und dachte,
ja, das ist eigentlich amüsant für so einen Podcast kurz vor so einer Wahl.
Prima. Dann sehen wir uns im Salon und wer da mit hingehen will,
der kann das Ganze einfach tun über Steady. Am allereinfachsten ist es,
auf neue20er.de zu gehen.
Dort ist ein goldener Button, da steht Salon.
Wenn man dort draufklickt, dann kommt man zu Steady und kann eines der drei
Abo-Pakete abschließen.
Ab 2,50 Euro ist man dabei.
Man hat dann die Möglichkeit, nicht nur diesen aktuellen Salon zu hören,
sondern in diesem Monat gibt es ja auch noch einen Live-Salon,
den wir in Frankfurt veranstalten.
Es geht um Emotionen dort.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, mein Lieber. Und dann kann man selbstredend auch all
die vergangenen Salons nachhören.
Also ein großes Archiv wartet da bereits.
Wer das also über Steady machen will, was wir empfehlen, kann das sehr, sehr leicht tun.
Ebenso einfach ist es, wenn man ein Patreon-Account hat, darüber das Abo abzuschließen.
Und für die, die ganz Apple...
Verliebt sind, die können das aber dann auch für etwas mehr Geld,
weil Apple eine höhere Gebühr verlangt, über Apple abschließen,
auch das ist kein Problem,
wer jetzt gerade uns über Spotify hört, kann auch da mal schauen,
da gibt es einen Button, dann kommt man sofort auf den Steady-Salon,
also mit wenigen Klicks ist es getan, es gibt in der Regel keine Probleme,
alle fünf Monate gibt es eine E-Mail, wo was nicht geklappt hat und darum kümmert
sich aber dann sofort Steady,
also es ist ganz einfach und Und man kann den Podcast ja dann überall hören,
weil man einen RSS-Feed bekommt.
Einen RSS-Feed oder man kann sogar bei Spotify hören, wenn man unbedingt bei Spotify hören will.
Also es ist ein ganz normaler Podcast, auch hinter der Paywall.
Es steht überall zur Verfügung.
Man bekommt die neue Folge automatisch. Man kriegt Kapitelmarken. Alles ganz normal.
Ja, drei, vier Stunden gibt es dann also nochmal Diskussionen über die wichtigen
Texte des Monats. Und wir weisen noch darauf hin, wir sind live zu erleben ja
immer in der CASE viermal im Jahr.
Diese Termine sind aber alle ausgebucht. Manchmal kommen noch E-Mails.
Da gibt es leider nichts mehr.
Aber im August machen wir ein großes Event, damit sich niemand beklagen kann.
Naja, euch kann man nie sehen, ist immer ausgebucht.
Und zwar sind wir da, auch in Frankfurt, aber in einem sehr,
sehr großen Saal. Und da gibt es auch noch Tickets.
Den Link findet ihr in der Beschreibung. Am 24. August sind wir da.
Ich schreibe dir nochmal rein, den haben wir die ganzen Monate gar nicht mehr
reingeschrieben, aber es gibt wohl noch, also der Saal ist 800 Plätze stark
und es gibt wohl noch so 120 ungefähr.
Ja, da kann also am Ende niemand sagen, es war ja kein Platz da,
sondern es ist ganz einfach da hinzukommen und dann sehen wir uns jetzt im Salon
mit Richard David Prechts Buch.
Bis gleich.